mit 19 000 kontrakte macht mehr her mit
wolf wenn ich höre ja immer meine
mentorin ein bisschen später deswegen
ist es das ist so komisch des todes
fischers fritz frisch frisch schritt
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video und 209 sache die ich
mir so ausgeguckt hat beziehungsweise
bei sixx halligalli haben sie das
gemacht dass unnötig komplizierte
interview joko klaas atze schröder
interviewt hat aber die hatten beide
kopfhörer obwohl ihre eigene stimme mit
einer halben sekunde verspätung gehört
haben mit teams wie kann man das
nachmachen deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
dass ich das eventuell auch mal hier
mache minecraft und dabei einfach eine
runde spieler so ich mache das jetzt
nämlich eben an ihr habt deswegen keine
ingame tun sondern einfach nur ein
bisschen lauter musik ich mache das
jetzt mal alle meine stimme wird sich so
verändern ihr könnt das er selbst war
machen bei teamspeak optionen test
starten und jetzt werde ich einfach eine
normale runde aufnehmen und das an
machen so los geht's meine liebe war das
also bevor jetzt sehr wohl was sagt dass
es sich hier total komisch anhören
ich muss los so ich hoffe meine kritik
ist scheiße aber ich hab eine suppe ich
werde geboxt ich werd geboxt weggeboxt
ich weggeboxt ich glaub jetzt in die
kanalisation da wo ich herkomme
es ist hier jemand hinter mir also die
rache ist es halt die bei teamspeak
mikrofon test kann man machen dass man
sein sein nico mikrofon dass man sein
mikrofon hört während man spricht das
habe ich jetzt gerade gerade gemacht
macht aber da hört man hört das ganze so
das team
man hört das ganze halt ein bisschen
später das heißt quasi hört auf eure
stimme und die ihr gehört quasi was ihr
eh ich kann das jetzt noch lauter machen
dann ist es noch noch schwieriger
deswegen ich mach das mal ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz laut dann höre ich versehen
meine stimme die ich quasi in den pc
drin deswegen bevor irgendjemand hier
von euch ankommt und mir in ihrem
kleinen form sagt dass ich das alles
spiele probiert es einfach selber war
aus systeme die mit dem wald in dein
herz geschrieben
ich war also köln mitteilte wenn ihr
mehr davon wollt dann könnt ihr ja
einfach mal einen daumen hoch gehen
ich habe mich gerade so als wär welchen
klein-klein ein kleines klingt irgendwie
ein klein klein des caddys kind wartet
auf den kopf gefallen ist
also leute ich versuche jetzt mal einen
satz so auf die reihe zu kriegen ohne
dass ich in irgendeiner form irgendwie
mich so anhöre als wäre ich in einer
murmel tier mögen
mit sprachfehler der satz kommt den drei
sekunden was solche boote zu sagen ich
lese jetzt irgendwelche heißt es aus dem
chelsea führt mit 19 000 kontrakte
machen mehr her mit wolf wind ich höre
ja immer mit meinen toren bisher wenig
später deswegen ist es das ist so
komisch des todes also wenn ich jedes
wort in diesen abstand rede ist
da sind folgt vor voll viele leute wenn
ich jedes wort so in die zellen abstand
dann funktioniert das alles sehr gut
aber wenn ich also einen kompletten satz
rede der mich runter geschossen bridget
breiner
wenn ich also einen kompletten satz rede
dann ist es halt immens komisch weil ich
mich halt wie immer und immer und immer
wieder höre ist ja da drauf gegangen mit
ihm kamera das nicht gut
ich versuche jetzt einfach mal den augen
der der ist auf jeden fall nicht mehr
mein teamkamerad los ich schreibe dann
los dass wir hier immer noch ein
bisschen ein bisschen action lag ranking
also leute vielleicht sagen jetzt welche
von euch ja bla bla bla
das doch alles nur probiert es ohne witz
ja ich bin tot oder aber per brücke
gekippt probierte jetzt ohne witz
einfach mal selber ausgeht den teams
bieten und liegt oben und geht auf
einstellungen dagegen auf optionen und
dann geht ihr auf mikrofon einstellungen
und dann dann gibt klicke auf test
starten
und wenn ihr euch anstrengt wird ihm
versucht einen vernünftigen satz mit
dieser mikrofon links zu sprechen nehmt
euch einfach mal auf oder sagt auch ein
kumpel soll sich neben mich setzen und
dann sondern machen
komisch also leute es war eine sehr
kurze runter komme ich ja hält auch 17
ich bin jetzt auch mal hinten da hinten
dran welche der tabak erhöht haben ich
geh jetzt einfach mal hier rein wie
lange dauert das sind das ist also leute
die vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht
wenn wenn wenn wenn wenn irgendwer der
dieses video irgendwie auf youtube film
das ist sehr sehr finden sollte und der
ihr irgendwie wie vor spielt auf
irgendeine stelle älter ländern in dem
video www video
ich glaube der wird er denke dass ich
das er sich irgendwie irgendwie entweder
der tektur oder oder wird wirklich je
eine sprache kranke glaube dass wenn man
das spiel spricht dann ist es halt halt
nicht so heftig also wenn du mich jetzt
ganz normal sprechen jungs also okay ich
versuche jetzt noch einmal einen satz zu
sprechen
irgendwie
ich sag jetzt zum brecher fischers fritz
frisch frisch rücktrittsfrist frische
fische frisch blaukraut bleibt blaukraut
und brautkleid bleibt brautkleid bleibt
brautkleid braun blau blaukraut bleibt
blaukraut und brautkleid bleibt
brautkleid wirtschafts fritz fritz
frisch rüssel freese ohne witz wenn ihr
wenn ihr wenn ihr fischers fritz sagt
wenn ihr wenn ihr die diese die bedingt
an habt ihr könntet es nicht warte ich
mach das jetzt mal ganz ganz ganz kurz
kurzem aus so ich habe es jetzt aus ich
kann ganz vernünftig reden wenn ich
jetzt sage fischers fritz fischt frische
fische ist schon ein bisschen komisch
aber nicht wieder anmachen ich rede ganz
normale ich rede jetzt mal einfach nur
über weiterhin wir in der runde für
sprit frischer fisch fischers fritz
fritz frischer frische fisch frisst
schritte frische fischer tritt gesprengt
ich lasse das jetzt wählte diese runde
und laufe der zeit einfach los ich kann
hier keine weg
ich glaube ich laufe einfach wieder in
die ich nehme ich jetzt einfach in die
mitte und ich werde einfach recht die
ich randalierer jetzt richtig renner
leiter die iren versuchen sofort und
schwert lustiger geht sofort auf mich
darauf der ddr scilla killer cooler typ
die leute dieser verschreibe kühlere
mein mann mann mann mann mann minecraft
kaka und ist es auch schon in diesem
team
teamspeak sprachsteuerung den briten so
freunde jetzt zum ende sage ich euch
nochmal einem einen platz einfach so so
läutet schreibt mir jetzt doch mal in
die idee kommt die kommentare objekte
darauf so eventuelle einsätze serie
haben wollt wo ich eventuell mit anderen
vielleicht auch alleine minecraft spiele
und da wird dabei die diese sprache
aktivierung an habe ich höre mir das
gleich weitere wales an wie ich mich
mich angehört habe aber so ganz grob wie
es euch halt gefallen hat wird wenn ihr
auf jeden fall mehr da wäre davon wolle
untergeht mit daumen hoch und schreib
mir doch mal mit den gegen kommentare
eine stelle
außerdem bittet wie die video ich habe
mir am meisten gefallen also dann will
ich sagen wenn man nächsten mal wieder
typisch